after a long day trust me there's no
reason that you can't make dinner at
home that's why today I'm putting the
challenge out there to see if Mir can do
it in just under 10 minutes
welcome to Ramsey in 10 hi I'm chef Mia
Castro and Chef Ramsay challenged me
today to make a pasta dish in under 10
minutes and I'm making an all-time
college favorite ramen cut your pepper
it's pasta with cacio cheese pepper a
pepper and I'm using ramen because it
cooks in two to three minutes and you
probably have it in your pantry anyways
already so let's start the clock and
let's get started this is some fresh
ramen if you don't have fresh ramen
which you can find in the refrigerated
section like your organic grocery store
you can just use your traditional your
traditional packaged ramen they both
cook in under 10 minutes the fresh one
cuts in two to three because it's fresh
and the one in the package it cooks in
about the same time so all these
ingredients are staples in my kitchen so
it's really easy for me to make when
I've came home from a busy day at work
or when it's really cold outside and I
want something hearty in here I have a
preheated pan just a little too hot so
I'm going to let it cool down and I'm
gonna put some olive oil some butter
they have Gordon's fancy Peppermill here
if you don't have this at home they sell
them at the grocery store
the disposable kind either one works the
same you're gonna get the same quality
meal and I like to do the pepper
straight into the butter cuz it gets it
it gets it really aromatic this is
another one of those ditches where you
don't have to measure everything you
kind of want to do everything by tasting
so it depends on how spicy you like it
how much pepper you're gonna add I'm
putting all the directions below anyway
just in case you need it
but it should be pretty easy for you to
make I'm just gonna test one of these
noodles ready so I'm gonna go straight
into the pan with the noodles and it's
actually good if you get some of that
pasta water in there because it'll help
you make a sauce with the starch to the
pan stir it around I'm actually gonna
add a little bit of that pasta water in
here and what that does is it makes a
really nice sauce when you combine it
with the cheese this is fresh grated
pecorino you can use parmesan as well
but I prefer the sharpness of the
pecorino new handfuls
move it around
and you can see there how the sauce is
starting to form pasta is one of my
favorite things to eat but I don't
always have time or I don't always
really want to cook so I like using
ramen in place of pasta and a lot of
dishes and I actually lived off of it in
college and I would make all sorts of
different things spaghetti
the cacio e pepe carbonara you can use
it anything with a little bit more water
and the beauty of ramen noodles is that
it cooks a lot faster than regular pasta
and it's cheap so you don't have to go
to a restaurant to get this dish
I'm gonna go ahead and taste it
a little bit more salt
so you need to be a little more careful
when you're using the traditional
packaged ramen because they cook faster
so you probably want to cook them a
little less when they're in the water
and as soon as they get really nice and
creamy and you get a really nice tight
sauce like that they're ready to serve I
have plenty of time to make this look
great right now
so you want to get fancy you just give
it that nice swirl on top with the tongs
give it a little height picture-perfect
and then just finish it off with a
sprinkling of pecorino and some fresh
cracked pepper this is a dish that you
can make in well under 10 minutes so
there's no excuse for you not to make
this at home
so boom ramen ketchup every Gordon under
10 minutes and under $10 leave a comment
below on what you think of this dish and
don't forget to subscribe to Gordon's
YouTube channel see you next time oh my
god when I was in ramen sorry
[Laughter]